- You like acting even more than singing?
I feel like we're opposites.
- We're, we're little bit,
yeah, we're opposites
and I, I think I kind of knew that
when I was going onto Idol,
I think I knew that I was gonna
try and go into television
and I wanted to sing,
but I've been really lucky to find shows
that have
- Yeah.
- both the acting and the singing,
like I did Smash
and now this newest one
with music and I, yeah, I think I,
I like hiding behind the
guise of somebody else.
I mean, I, being, putting an
album out like Katherine McPhee
or Kelly Clarkson,
- Yeah.
- there's so much,
there's something so
vulnerable about that,
not that I'm--
- I have never named an
album Kelly Clarkson.
- Okay.
- There's a reason.
- There's a reason maybe.
- Yeah, it's a lot of pressure.
- I made that mistake, the first album.
- Oh, I did not do that.
I was like, can't do it.
- Yeah, but there's,
there's something, you know,
it's, you're selling yourself, right.
Like you are the instrument
and so, I don't know, I
think I just really like
standing behind somebody's words
and whether I connect
to those words or not
as a different person
- Yeah.
- and so, yeah, I've always,
I've always liked acting,
but I didn't realize that
it would be the thing
that I really ended up pursuing.
I was already pursuing it
before I went on Idol, but
- Yeah.
- I kind of went,
I spent a lot of,
a lot of years auditioning for stuff
and not getting them
and making relationships,
so yeah I love it.
- I think you're right.
I tell people that like
artists on The Voice that too,
that are on my team or
even on other teams,
I'm like don't look at this
as, this is your big thing,
- Right.
- Look at this as like
the next step
- The next stop.
because even after I won,
like I was playing like
state fair is nobody,
like, it was hard.
- Oh yeah.
- Like, like it,
you, you still have to keep working,
like it doesn't just
- Oh yeah.
- like overnight.
- Well, 'cause Idol is a, an amazing,
it's like a camp right
where you're learning stuff,
but I, I did not know anything
about live performing.
I didn't know how to command a stage,
I did the same thing, I did state fairs
and there was literally,
it was, it could have filled 10,000 people
and there were a hundred people there
and I had to really learn,
- Yeah.
- you know,
that helped my acting.
- To navigate back.
- To navigate that--
- Humility.
- How's everyone doing out there?
(clapping)
(laughing)
- And I was like, okay, I'm gonna just.
- Just gonna nail this for all 12 of you.
- All 12 of you,
but I had several shows like that,
- Yeah.
- like hundreds of shows
like that.
- It builds character.
- It does, it builds character.
- It, yeah.
- And you learn how to just
kind of push through it and,
and find a way to enjoy it just
for what it is, no matter how
many people are out there.
So it helped both singing
and acting I think.
- I love that.